was machen wir jetzt ich weiß es nicht
der Ramadankalender ist da wie sagen wir
das den leenmer no K ja wofür bezahlen
wir die überhaupt also bitte Kiki das
ist doch super einfach am Anfang zeigt
dir hamser wie der wieder an seinen 1000
Grafiken arbeitet der soll sich aber
wirklich anstrengen weil meistens sieht
das so aus als wird der eigentlich gar
nicht arbeiten Schwitzen oder so wäre
gut dann kommst du soum diecke und sagst
Hamsa du siehst echt gestresst aus gönn
die meine Praline und dann endlich habt
ihr die Idee warte mal kurz machen ein
Moment ich hab es gleich auf auf jeden
Fall sagt hams dann das ist doch die
Idee ein Ramadan pralinalender dann
blendet ihr dann meine krassen Videos
ein damit die Leute endlich mal checken
wie lecker diese praninen sind und ey du
hattest mir doch was von zwei neuen
Sorten erzählt oder nicht gib den Leuten
noch mal einen kleinen Spoiler und bitte
schreib mir in Zukunft nicht mehr nach
Feierabend
ciao